fa vj è un figo non so se ho capito bene
hai capito benissimo amica mia fantasia
ma ristorante in centro a torino che c'e
voglia di far festa
non so chi sia tua zia poi come con una
serie di ristoranti sono a torino questa
è una donna coi contro maroni ragazzi
tutti ragazzi e prendete persona video
sono parigi
ok ho trovato questo su internet
foruncolo e favo c hai azzeccato in
piena vita mia con che i ragazzi siano
sull'ipod che è un prodotto della pera
siccome molti di voi ma nokia triste
l'affare video sull'ipad
siccome non si vive mi chiedono spesso
di iniziare a fare video sul ipad sulle
applicazioni ho fatto che scaricare
permetterà la più giocata che sarebbe
asphalt asphalt 8 ecco perfetto ci sono
dei problemi tecnici quindi ragazzi
decisioni farne un video su questo sono
forma io sono bravissima si giochi
sappiatelo posso prendere questo gioco
mi piace è talmente [ __ ] che mi verrebbe
da leccare l'ipad però mi contengo cioè
io nei giochi di macchine ragazzi cioè i
riflessi di un bradipo sul serio e non è
uno scherzo però ci provo lo stesso
perché ne vada
madonna macché grafica accesso giochi
per ipad è possibile sempre anzi già
partiti
insomma partite prima come si gioca
tanta gente non vuole anche che a me va
bene dell'ottavo giro aperti ve l'avevo
detto che era un fenomeno prima mente
ragazzi io e le curve siamo come due
fratelli venuti
ce lo vedi questo nella marmitta ragazzi
e fantastico sentite sinistra ma perché
se so che io lo amo sto gioco regala non
avete capito che immagina io ci vado a
modo mio niente i ragazzi non vi
conviene allarmi come autista non so io
ve lo dico in amicizia e poi fate quello
che ho detto vi ricordate che se
prendete un taxi non come lo può
comprare sto tizio se prendete tipo un
taxi e mi trovate come mi trovate al
volante c'è scendete ve lo dico proprio
riusciti a beccare il muro ma sono
quelli in piedi giaccone che cosa è
successo che il sì che si che apportano
a caso se va bene ma se ma certo cosa
sto se cosentino fatto ragazzino non mi
fa non fate domande perché non ho capito
neanche aveva fatto però perché sono
gallerie normali cercato di capire ma
non lo faccio apposta ma anche per se
stesso un piccione che cazzo ci fa un
piccione finisce primo ho vinto ho vinto
ho vinto la 20 temi che sono ragazzi mi
segno data e ora perché non ho mai vinto
un gioco di macchine in vita mia mai
magari giuro lasciam perdere ragazzi
andiamo avanti così ai crediti
sufficienti per sbloccarci per la
madonna 6 st marchi nella vita reale non
c'è maicon a 6 cent
prendo la mini cooper qualche mese mi
sento troppo un ganzo ragazzi voi non
avete idea di quanto mi pesa l'ipad con
stapperà dietro ci sono io che sono
stupidi già partiti che cassetto
conto alla rovescia più più veloce della
storia perfetto se io io ero abituato a
quartiere a 49 però partiamo pure da tre
guardalo madonna ma sono forte legame ti
togli dai cazzo a voce eve diventati
contro di me della tv non posso andare
avanti così 76 matata sta macchina
[Musica]
[Applauso]
sì ma sentitemi non è che posso andare a
fare frontali con le macchine a casa e
viabile e la strada manco guidare
canzoni dalla patente a sta gente merda
no c'è verso ok dove siamo
insomma sono sesto non ultimo fantastico
retto non riuscita a riva
mi sa che la rai ormai più primo nella
storia però è bello bordon basta basta
dopo questo basta cosa cazzo affatto
ragazzi replay subito
[Musica]
c'ero ero arrivato primo e adesso
l'ultima in 4 secondi grazie
minchia che botta in autostrada se vi
capita di vedere una macchina così sono
io ecco vedi fantastici ho fatto dieci
fronte che faccia con un transformer sa
cos'è sta roba ragazzi vabbè salve le
dispiace se ne passa sotto le gambe
perfetto e uno no sì ma dorme chi
affronta le ha fatto quel tizio
vorrei vedere il ragazzo si finisce
sinistro finisce fini vivo di un secondo
è però va già bene così per me ragazzi
sarà un caso che io mica dei giochi di
macchine perché vi giuro che non è mai
successo ma vi giuro è una cosa che ho
una mamma che fanno il conto alla
rovescia così in fretta
non sono pronto beh ragazzi migliori la
gara decente stavolta anche se non si
capisce come mai vinco anche tu sei
matto
ragazzi non so voi ma sta dubstep di
sottofondo mi carica di brutto
a stronzi siete voi credete di andare a
vela la potenza della fera ragazzi la
pena che fa tutto lei che cosa per che
cazzo era quello è spuntata una roccia
casa dall'autrice mimì lanciano i sassi
di mancini stasera non si sa dove
ragazzi tra le guarda anche l'altro
anche altro
sì l'ho superato superato no 1 se si
pigia carreggiata laica box ragazzi sono
un [ __ ] dai vera forza fumetti litro
a questo va in mezzo alla strada un
deficiente dai se ami cambiati facevano
essere un amichetto si chiama guard rail
e simpatico ho spiegato che non vi nome
donne ho visto un concorrente per eccolo
eccolo maragall aprendo lo fa il momento
della duster carica su ciò che ho fatto
non è cazzo cazzo trovargli tirare palle
non ci credo non ci voglio perché non ci
voglio credere
vittoria della madonna basta ragazzi
dopo pezzo ha vinto tutto espulsione che
se questo che ogni volta e li tiene più
auto dell'avversario
ok ovviamente ragazzi questo devo fare
lo farei bravo autista c'è da andare
contro le altre macchine per buttarle
giù fantastico 100 watt e dirmelo prima
ragazzi intera con applicazioni per ipad
ma figata pazzesca
io le butto giù questa è una curva cazzo
una curva decente lo dici a buttarlo giù
queste
minchia che mira 22 troppo pro cazzo se
butto giù l'euro vale 2
si ok siamo a crederci sì vado a ma
spesso è morto per gli oli perfetto cosa
ho fatto cos'è sto salto della madonna
si dice che becco il muro uno ce ne
ragazzi ci avrei scommesso la pena 0
presa e poi ci sono quei giorni qui le
macchine cadono dal cielo senza motivo
ripresa eccolo lì perfetto il mio amico
guard rail
c'è sempre sette secondi no 5 cazzo mi
rimane una mary ma nessuno me l'ha in
mano una una ce l'ho presa e l'ho presa
di terni che un secondo mancava estero a
chi fa prima che a province ragazzi non
fate domande su come non ne ho idea
mi sono salvato per culo lasciam perdere
comunque ho vinto era questa mia versato
dio schema di oba oba tutto dio è chiaro
dorica direi che posso concludere po
perché è stato è stato istruttivo
soprattutto se da venissero db lezioni
di guida
io ci sono ragazzi ma tipo nevada ho
fatto cinque fottute stelle il mio dio
non l'avesse riuscita a fare meglio di
così mandatemi uno screen per me che ho
fatto due minuti se fatte meno di due
minuti mandatemi uno screen sembra che
non ci sia tanto ragazzi potete farlo
perché si trova sia sull'app store per
ipad e iphone che su suv stop agli
android quindi se mi batte poi montate
milo screen malan
comunque non ho capito perché ho
comprato 200 macchine alla fine stato
solo non stata una praticamente però va
bene che sia stato un ottimo lezione di
scuola guida ragazzi perché io ci so
fare
c'è poco da dire tutti ragazzi se il
vino è l'app è la pera vi sono piaciuti
lasciate un commento mi piace anche a
pagina di facebook come non i video
trovate la descrizione se non resti
scheletrici vediamo il prossimo vinto
belle ragazze